SPEAKER_00: Good morning, Amanda. Let's talk about your investment portfolio and risk tolerance.
SPEAKER_01: Perfect timing. I've been-- I've been losing sleep over the market volatility lately.
SPEAKER_00: That's actually a good sign that we should review your risk allocation. When did you start feeling uncomfortable?
SPEAKER_01: Probably around the banking crisis earlier this year. My portfolio dropped like fifteen percent in two weeks.
SPEAKER_00: And how did that make you feel? Did you consider selling?
SPEAKER_01: Honestly? Yeah. I kept checking my account balance multiple times a day.
SPEAKER_00: That's a classic sign you might be taking more risk than you're comfortable with. Let's review your current allocation. What do you have right now?
SPEAKER_01: Um, mostly Canadian and US stocks. Maybe eighty-five percent equities, fifteen percent bonds.
SPEAKER_00: That's quite aggressive. What's your age again?
SPEAKER_01: Thirty-eight.
SPEAKER_00: So the traditional rule of thumb would be sixty-two percent stocks, thirty-eight percent bonds. You're significantly more aggressive than that.
SPEAKER_01: I thought you were supposed to be aggressive when you're young?
SPEAKER_00: You can be, but only if you can handle the volatility emotionally. If you're losing sleep and wanting to sell during downturns, that's counterproductive.
SPEAKER_01: So what should I be thinking about?
SPEAKER_00: Risk tolerance has multiple dimensions. There's your financial capacity for risk - how much you can afford to lose. And your emotional tolerance - how much volatility you can handle.
SPEAKER_01: What's my financial capacity?
SPEAKER_00: Well, you're making... what was it... eighty-five thousand? Good job security, no dependents, emergency fund in place. You can probably handle significant volatility financially.
SPEAKER_01: But emotionally it's harder?
SPEAKER_00: Seems like it. And that's totally normal. The key is finding an allocation where you won't panic-sell during the inevitable downturns.
SPEAKER_01: How do we figure that out?
SPEAKER_00: Let's run through some scenarios. In two thousand and eight, the S&P five hundred dropped about fifty-seven percent peak to trough. How would you feel if your portfolio dropped fifty percent?
SPEAKER_01: Terrified. I'd probably sell everything.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, so we need to design a portfolio where even in a severe bear market, your losses feel manageable. What about a thirty percent drop?
SPEAKER_01: That would still be scary, but... maybe I could stick it out?
SPEAKER_00: Good. So we want to target maximum drawdowns around thirty percent. That probably means something like sixty-forty stocks to bonds, maybe seventy-thirty.
SPEAKER_01: But won't that hurt my long-term returns?
SPEAKER_00: A bit, yes. But here's the thing - if you panic-sell during a crash, you lock in those losses. Better to have lower returns but actually stay invested.
SPEAKER_01: That makes sense. What kind of returns are we talking about?
SPEAKER_00: Historically, a sixty-forty portfolio has averaged around... um... seven too eight percent annually. Your current eighty-five fifteen might do nine to ten percent, but with much higher volatility.
SPEAKER_01: Is one to two percent difference that big a deal?
SPEAKER_00: Over thirty years? It's significant. But only if you actually earn those returns. If you sell during crashes and miss the recovery, you could do much worse.
SPEAKER_01: Good point. What about within the stock allocation?
SPEAKER_00: Good question. You mentioned Canadian and US stocks. What's the split there?
SPEAKER_01: Maybe fifty-fifty? I've got VTI for US and VCN for Canada.
SPEAKER_00: That's pretty home country biased. Canada's only about three percent of global market cap, but you've got fifty percent there.
SPEAKER_01: Is that bad?
SPEAKER_00: Not necessarily. Canadian dividends get better tax treatment, and currency hedging has value. But you're missing out on diversification.
SPEAKER_01: What would proper diversification look like?
SPEAKER_00: Maybe twenty-five percent Canada, forty percent US, twenty percent international developed, fifteen percent emerging markets. Something like that. Actually, let me double-check those allocations for you.
SPEAKER_01: Emerging markets seem risky.
SPEAKER_00: They are more volatile, but they're also cheaper on valuation metrics. Plus, when Canadian and US markets struggle, sometimes international does better.
SPEAKER_01: Like a hedge?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. In twenty twenty-two, Canadian stocks actually outperformed US stocks. International diversification helped Canadian investors that year.
SPEAKER_01: What about bonds? I just have a broad Canadian bond index.
SPEAKER_00: That's fine for the core holding. Though you might consider some US or global bonds for currency diversification. Maybe seventy percent Canadian, thirty percent international bonds.
SPEAKER_01: Interest rates have been all over the place lately.
SPEAKER_00: They have. Bond prices move inverse to rates, so when rates rise, bond prices fall. We've seen that this year.
SPEAKER_01: So maybe bonds aren't great right now?
SPEAKER_00: Well, higher rates mean better yields going forward. A five percent bond yield is much more attractive than the two percent we had a few years ago.
SPEAKER_01: But what if rates keep going up?
SPEAKER_00: Then bond prices would fall further. But remember, if you hold to maturity, you get your principal back. And you're earning higher coupons along the way.
SPEAKER_01: What about different types of bonds?
SPEAKER_00: You could mix government and corporate bonds. Maybe some inflation-protected bonds too. Real return bonds have done well when inflation's been high.
SPEAKER_01: How much inflation protection do I need?
SPEAKER_00: Depends on your time horizon. Over thirty years, even modest inflation compounds significantly. Maybe ten to twenty percent of your bond allocation?
SPEAKER_01: What about alternatives? REITs, commodities, that stuff?
SPEAKER_00: They can add diversification, but they're generally more volatile than bonds. REITs are essentially real estate stocks - they move more like equities.
SPEAKER_01: So they wouldn't help in a stock market crash?
SPEAKER_00: Not necessarily. In two thousand and eight, REITs fell almost as much as stocks. Though they've provided good income over time.
SPEAKER_01: What about gold? Everyone talks about gold.
SPEAKER_00: Gold can be a hedge against currency debasement and inflation. But it produces no income and can be very volatile. Maybe five percent maximum.
SPEAKER_01: This is getting complicated. How do I keep track of all this?
SPEAKER_00: That's where target allocation comes in. You set percentage targets for each asset class, then rebalance periodically back to those targets.
SPEAKER_01: How often should I rebalance?
SPEAKER_00: Quarterly or semi-annually is common. More frequent rebalancing can create tax issues in non-registered accounts. Less frequent and you drift too far from your targets.
SPEAKER_01: What about taxes on rebalancing?
SPEAKER_00: In your RRSP and TFSA, no tax consequences. In taxable accounts, selling winners triggers capital gains. That's why many people rebalance with new contributions instead.
SPEAKER_01: So add new money to whatever's underweight?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. If stocks have done well and you're overweight, put new money into bonds until you're back on target.
SPEAKER_01: What if I need to withdraw money?
SPEAKER_00: Take it from whatever's overweight. That way withdrawals also help with rebalancing.
SPEAKER_01: This sounds like a lot of work.
SPEAKER_00: It doesn't have to be. You could use a single balanced ETF like VBAL or VGRO. They do the rebalancing automatically.
SPEAKER_01: What's the difference between those two?
SPEAKER_00: VBAL is sixty percent stocks, forty percent bonds. VGRO is eighty percent stocks, twenty percent bonds. Based on our discussion, VBAL might suit you better.
SPEAKER_01: And it's all-in-one?
SPEAKER_00: Yep. Global diversification, automatic rebalancing, low fees. Takes the complexity out of portfolio management.
SPEAKER_01: What are the fees?
SPEAKER_00: VBAL is... um... point two two percent annually, I think? Much cheaper than actively managed funds.
SPEAKER_01: Versus what I have now?
SPEAKER_00: VTI and VCN are even cheaper - maybe point zero five percent each. But you have to do the rebalancing yourself.
SPEAKER_01: Is the convenience worth the extra cost?
SPEAKER_00: That's personal preference. For many people, the automatic rebalancing and diversification is worth point one five percent annually.
SPEAKER_01: What about during market crashes? Do these funds hold up?
SPEAKER_00: They'll still go down, but less than pure equity funds. In March twenty twenty, VBAL dropped about twenty percent versus thirty-five percent for stock funds.
SPEAKER_01: That's still a lot.
SPEAKER_00: It is, but it recovered much faster. By the end of twenty twenty, VBAL was actually positive for the year.
SPEAKER_01: How do I know if I can handle a twenty percent drop?
SPEAKER_00: Think about it in dollar terms. If you have a hundred thousand invested, twenty percent is twenty thousand dollars. How would you feel seeing that loss?
SPEAKER_01: Sick to my stomach, but maybe not panicked?
SPEAKER_00: That sounds like you could handle it. The key is remembering it's temporary if you stay invested.
SPEAKER_01: What about sequence of returns risk?
SPEAKER_00: That's more relevant when you're withdrawing money, like in retirement. Poor returns early on can really hurt if you're taking distributions.
SPEAKER_01: But I'm still-- I'm still accumulating?
SPEAKER_00: Right, so market crashes actually help you. You're buying more shares at lower prices with each contribution.
SPEAKER_01: I never thought of it that way.
SPEAKER_00: It's counterintuitive, but true. The worst thing for someone your age would be markets going straight up until you retire, then crashing.
SPEAKER_01: Because I'd have no chance to buy at lower prices?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Some volatility along the way is actually helpful for long-term wealth building.
SPEAKER_01: So maybe I should be less worried about short-term drops?
SPEAKER_00: As long as you're not planning to retire in the next five years, short-term volatility is just noise. It's the long-term trend that matters.
SPEAKER_01: What about black swan events? Things we can't predict?
SPEAKER_00: By definition, you can't prepare for truly unforeseeable events. But diversification helps. Don't put all your eggs in one basket.
SPEAKER_01: Geographic diversification too?
SPEAKER_00: Absolutely. If Canada goes through a prolonged recession, having US and international exposure helps.
SPEAKER_01: What about sector diversification?
SPEAKER_00: Also important. Canadian markets are heavily weighted toward financials and resources. US markets give you more tech and healthcare exposure.
SPEAKER_01: Should I be worried about currency risk?
SPEAKER_00: Some, but currency movements work both ways. A weak Canadian dollar actually helps your foreign investments.
SPEAKER_01: And currency hedging?
SPEAKER_00: Reduces volatility but costs money and isn't perfect. For long-term investors, unhedged is often fine.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, so what's my action plan?
SPEAKER_00: I'd suggest transitioning too something like VBAL gradually. Maybe sell a third of your current holdings each month over three months.
SPEAKER_01: Why gradually?
SPEAKER_00: Reduces the risk of bad timing. You might sell everything right before a rally, or right before a crash.
SPEAKER_01: Dollar cost averaging again?
SPEAKER_00: Right. It doesn't guarantee better results, but it eliminates the stress of trying to time the transition perfectly.
SPEAKER_01: And then just stick with it?
SPEAKER_00: Pretty much. Review annually to make sure it still fits your situation, but avoid tinkering based on market movements.
SPEAKER_01: This feels much more manageable.
SPEAKER_00: Good. The best investment strategy is one you can stick with through all market conditions. Sounds like we found that for you.
SPEAKER_01: Thanks for helping me think through this.
SPEAKER_00: My pleasure. Better to adjust now than panic-sell during the next market crash.